so this isn't some random dude this is
pretending to be ryan reynolds as the
super buff guy they're like here's what
we filmed and then we deleted it did you
guys stop watching the foreground
characters and just start looking at the
background
[Music]
thanks to bessie for sponsoring this
video stick around so you can see how
you can get 25 off your order today hey
everybody welcome back to another
episode of visual effects artists react
i'm joined by ren and sam and we got
some great clips to look at today we got
space jam we have darby o'gilly and the
little people what
that
darby jesse wait also loki is finally
completely released on disney plus so we
are finally gonna be diving into that
you know it's a really exciting time for
movies because in the last two weeks
i've seen two movies in theaters and
it's awesome i saw black widow and i saw
old just for the fun of it does anybody
get old
they get old old half
all right let's watch the clips
you picked up the tesseract breaking
reality
i want you to help us fix it i haven't
seen loki yet loki is great honestly i
think it's my favorite marvel show
they've made yet i'm a sucker for time
loops and time messing stuff so low-key
was a lot of fun but there's a cg
character in the show that is inspired
by very old-timey cartoon effects and it
was really interesting what they had to
do to bring this character to life and
that would lead to the destruction of
the timeline and the collapse of reality
as we know it there's lighting yeah
there's interactive lighting oh is the
desk completely cg
watch it where's your manners
oh hey quit it so one of the challenges
they found for this was trying to marry
the real world photography in camera
with the digital version of miss minutes
because she's transparent they actually
had this really cool little led light
system that they had that they would
actually move around to get the
interactive lighting on the set but then
they would have to paint out that light
and what people don't realize is it's
not just simply a matter of painting out
a light yeah like they're filming in a
dim office like you're setting yourself
up for a challenge they went through a
lot of effort just to recreate the
background so that it looks normal and
then they would re-light it after the
fact so i don't actually know how useful
this light ended up being at the end of
the day look at the actual color quality
on the ground on the light around it and
then look at the final thing that's just
a new shot it's all cg it's basically a
new shot yeah exactly hold on i don't
know i don't know what they're saying
but what i'm seeing is they're like
here's what we filmed and then we
deleted it
no that's exactly it it was purely for
reference you can see her reflection on
the tea kettle and then when they show
the actual light that they built it's a
completely different reflection so they
end up having to recreate so much of
what you see you know that's the thing
we're always talking about the best
looking images are when you combine
practical and digital the problem is
that it usually doesn't work as
seamlessly or as well as you might
imagine it should at the very least you
get the lighting on tom hiddleston that
is true one last thing from loki that i
want to touch on is this idea of blue
screening anything
it looks like a tough blue screen right
there granted this is probably taken on
a less high quality camera than the one
they're filming with the sensor is
probably going whoa that's a lot of blue
and making it look like way crazier than
it does in the footage that's a good
point that might actually be the case if
i was sent the shot to key out the blue
but i gotta keep the ground i gotta keep
the people what do you do you cut it out
by hand cut it out by hand that's the
answer when it comes to keying something
it's usually a whole bunch of talented
roto artists yeah they're going in and
they're making very accurate and
detailed track mats the same way that
we've done for a hundred years if they
tried to swap that out with the green
screen yeah it'd be easier to key out
but now you're introducing trouble with
a green spill so by keeping it blue yes
it's gonna require a little bit more
manual work but the end result is gonna
look better i think there's over 500
shots just in episode five every shot is
basically movie level caliber they're
all pretty impressive i mean disney
probably went you have ten thousand
dollars per second and they're simply
looking at every second of footage but
like ten thousand dollars you want to
make this one second better they do that
for every second of the episodes
wait how much money is that that's a lot
of money i think that might be a little
more money than you can handle let's
find out actually 50 times 60 times 60
times 10
1.8 billion little high let's knock that
a down dollars per second the most
expensive movie ever made i i do find it
pretty fascinating though that the
entire budget for loki was around 150
million dollars and that's the budget of
a pretty big blockbuster movie 150
million in production costs they
actually might have been more expensive
a thousand dollars per second for 55
minutes siri one hundred and four
hundred four thousand dollars episodes
six seven eight thousand five i already
did that no no no no no no no no each
episode
50 minutes so it's 500 000
so then
divided by 60
833 i know it was eight thousand it's
almost ten thousand dollars a second i
call it you just did the math wrong you
just did the math wrong i didn't i got
the same i got the exact same number you
did no no i know but before when you got
the one billion number your thumb
slipped or something yeah when i got
guessed it was ten thousand dollars a
second i actually was not that okay so
anyways full circle niko's right we are
so beyond the effects artist react right
now look this vfx always have to deal
with money this is totally vfx honest
reaction i can be honest there's a part
of me that hates how expensive this
stuff is yeah
you're just jealous i'm me too
happening
space jam a new legacy i have not seen
this movie yet i used to like the
original space jam and then i actually
rewatched it and was disappointed by how
it didn't hold up
this means war
so i am noticing that the furry cartoon
characters have a nice little layer of
fur but all the skin characters doesn't
quite look like properly skin shaded
like maybe slightly lacking a little bit
i know how gross and weird would it look
like if the cartoon characters had this
like fleshy translucent skin they have
to have that toy feel i feel like listen
braun braun this is basketball but with
a spin to it does seeing all the cg
characters does it feel like that kind
of takes it away from the cartoon aspect
of things well in the original space jam
there's a bit of a technological marvel
with it whereas michael jordan who is a
human being in a cartoon world for most
of it and eventually cartoons joining
him on the court which is a bit of roger
rabbit kind of thing yeah totally a
pretty big deal like from a visual
effects standpoint at this point not
that big of a deal when lebron james
goes to toon world he becomes a cartoon
also there is no photoreal lebron james
with cartoon characters they just
skipped that entirely he's got honey
straight cartoon rabbit season all right
yeah now say i'm hot and white oh
there's your chungus dude they actually
put big chunkis in the movie did we just
catch this one glimpse of him being a
chungus
there you go that's a reference
and you know what else is brilliant
this ball movement the visual effects
are great but there's so much happening
that it makes it really hard to find a
focus to the scene because i i'm trying
to watch the characters and they look
awesome it's just like holy crap there
is so much happening it's like almost a
visual overload did you guys stop
watching the foreground characters and
just start looking at the background oh
my god there are so many characters in
the background is this basically just
ready player one but with basketball
ready player basketball and with only
warner brothers franchise yeah there's
the wicked witch there's a clown from it
oh hey it's them the family even came
space jam has decent visual effects in
it but there's my opinion a
miscalculation here so movie crowds
generally for the most part the job with
crowds is you just want an anonymous
mass of people in the background but
what if you go hey what if i pick as
many popular characters as i can and
just sprinkle them throughout the crowd
so the audience is just playing where's
waldo with the crowd the whole time what
that does is it makes you immediately go
well i'm gonna stop watching the
foreground i'm gonna start watching the
background and all the little tricks
that you can do for a crowd suddenly
break down for example
in the background watch eye lines and
watch hype levels
come here buddy
so penguin he's not looking at any of
the action well maybe he's noticing
other characters he recognizes on the
other side
everybody is hyped a hundred percent the
entire time it just doesn't stop
everyone's always cheering even when
people are quiet on the sidelines people
are screaming and clapping you're right
it's funny because i'm trying to like
look at the characters but i'm more
interested in the people they're
featuring yeah like there's that monkey
in the background dancing that's who i'm
looking at yeah the other thing is that
you have to populate hundreds if not
thousands of 3d models of people for all
of those extras in the background just
so that you can then
blur them all out of focus yeah this is
a whole third of the movie basically i
spent the entire scene just looking at
the background i forgot entirely what
happened
in the actual foreground of the camera
here i didn't see any value that's
replay value yeah but like i wonder
though isn't that the fun part of this
movie is noticing all those i mean i
like
trying to spot these characters i do too
i do too it's just it's an odd choice
so you might be able to tell which
aliens are fake in space jam but can you
tell which aliens are fake in the
pentagon ufo videos that were recently
released sam and i sat down to apply our
visual effects art aside to see if we
could debunk and explain the ufo videos
this video is coming out tomorrow on
this channel tune back and then or
subscribe so you don't miss it
so here we have darby o'gill and the
little people this is a movie about a
man who i think catches a leprechaun and
gets like wishes and all kind of stuff
and here he is in their kingdom and he's
going to play them in some music and
they're going to have a good old time
wait you're telling me his wish was to
rule the kingdom of leprechauns i don't
know you have to watch movie to find out
where we go one two three four
look at that cutie
[Laughter]
oh oh oh oh that's crazy what
wait what no green screens
oh oh oh oh
it's getting crazier
dude he's fiddling so hard it's like i
brought you a magical instrument from
the human realm and they're all like my
bodies we can't control them
what are you doing to us
i won't stop playing until you give me
your gold
i mean are we seeing a bunch of like
forced perspective stuff let's talk
about force perspective real quick so in
order to make something look big and
something else looks small back in the
day before you can just cut people out
and move them around your screen with
your computer you basically need to have
your at one actor be close to the camera
and the other actors be far away because
at the end of the day the camera is just
giving you a two-dimensional image you
can't look at the image and tell what's
close and far outside of just the cues
of what you're looking at on screen so
you can fake it so that's how they had
to approach this because you know you
don't have green screens you don't have
computers they can do matting where they
can cut something out and stick in the
frame but that doesn't really let you
move around you can force perspective
this one where you have him really close
to the camera and then a large set in
the background but watch as he walks off
this shot's amazing if you're going to
do forced perspective with this there's
going to be a seam in your set there
would be a cutoff there of a platform
that's raised up and closer to us and
then like a larger floor that's in the
background so what they did is they
actually designed their set to have
these streaks painted on it and they
matched the paint lines from the little
platform close to the camera to the
platform behind the camera same thing
with this pause right there oh i see it
yep
that's really well lined up they're
using the curvature of the rock to
motivate the seam a little bit there you
can really see the edges once you start
looking for it but i love this it's so
cool okay but what about that shot i
think this is just a matte that's got to
be a matted shot because that'd be a
matted shot you can't do that you can't
do that you can't do it you can't do
that but the thing is for this we have a
matted shot it means that he didn't just
go stand there on the set because that
part of the set is like that's like a 50
foot high scene wait a minute what if
he's on a platform that's hanging in the
center of a room he could be because you
think how tall would that ceiling have
to be and how much work we have to put
into that ceiling to build that i think
that's not a real ceiling i think that's
a matte painting if that's a matte
painting that means that he could be
standing on scaffolding and the matte
painting's just covered in the entire
scaffolding oh is this the behind the
scenes for a vet yep that's totally a
freaking platform the doll's in the
foreground
they're just rotating them
sticks
oh show us how it was done please please
hold on all right let's repeat this
i forgot about mirrors
that's all dolls and mirrors
wow
it was a mirror it's not just a mirror
it's a mirror where they cut a hole
through the mirror there's no mats at
all this is all 100 in camera this is
insane and there's a matte painting too
the ceiling and the stalactites and
stuff i also painted on glass in front
of the mirror right off the front of the
camera it makes total sense now we got
to keep that in our back pocket each
time we see those old things we're like
it could be a mirror now yeah i forgot
about mirrors i completely forgot about
mirrors as a legit trick
so ryan reynolds has a new movie out
called free guy and what i like about
what ryan reynolds does with the
marketing is that he takes an
untraditional approach instead of doing
a classic trailer you know he does this
thing where it's like it starts out as a
trailer and then turns into an interview
with a monstrosity and nico i wanted to
get your opinion on this shot okay yeah
i don't have time for that i've been at
this one week
wow so this isn't some random dude this
is pretending to be ryan reynolds as the
super buff guy is that just prosthetic
or is that a deep fake because it kind
of looks like a deep fake every once in
a while here's the first thing we can
look at let's watch his adam's apple
and i gotta tell you
it's coming in nicely it's just staying
building it's not moving oh it's not
moving anymore ryan say some words this
is me pretending to be ryan reynolds
because we look exactly the same and i
am talking now and you can see my adam's
apple
for this to be a deep fake the muscular
dude needs to be doing the performance
because a deep fake is just a mask it
isn't actually somebody else's
performance pasted on your face it's
your performance you just are wearing a
mask and therefore you would see
evidence like in this adam's apple of it
moving as these lines are coming up in
this shot we see it in that shot we see
it in the first shot we don't but it's
it's not quite lined up that is the
reason why i think it's not a deep fake
because that would mean the actor
whoever this buff dude is is having to
not only deliver the same lines that
ryan reynolds is gonna have to say he's
gonna have to say at the exact same
timing and the exact same inflection and
now that means ryan reynolds
famous charisma is now locked into
whatever this bodybuilder is doing with
his face but what's the facial
performance it's not that crazy i feel
like you could totally just go hey we
need a buff dude who can like do a
couple jokes i i feel like that's
totally possible because the motion on
the face it's like yeah it could be like
a 2d semi-3d track but it looks like a
deep fake it looks like the facial
motion you see in a deep fake it does
look like a deep fake i'm going to guess
that it's not a deep fake my reason for
that is i think what they did here is
they just filmed ryan reynolds locked
off directly facing camera very low
perspective changes and he just does all
his performance and they pace the face
onto this guy and deal with a little bit
of morphing and stretching to make like
the jawline move and stuff like that
still really well done and the fact that
we're even discussing it like this is
you know especially for a quick little
promo piece commercial it's like yeah
real quick though there's another video
that they did for the marketing for free
guy that i feel is particularly relevant
to this show
well hello there and what's up reaction
faction it's deadpool i'll be reacting
to a trailer for a movie which i
honestly thought came out like a year
ago wow
i would like to think that this is like
a shout out to
us but there's plenty of other reactions
yeah there's lots of react formats out
there we are not original in any regard
however it is kind of cool to see a
similar format being used in marketing
for this i do feel like there's only one
reaction out there where it just has a
straight up couch in the middle of the
shot maybe they're joking about us
maybe they're having a laugh
ryan i know you're watching this right
now we're talking about your movie i
know you're seeing this if you want to
talk about this more hit us up and you
can sit on this couch with us and maybe
we can look at the green lantern and you
can clarify what you've been wanting to
clarify for a long time yeah exactly you
can come on our show you can sit in this
seat right here wren
[Music]
he'll go to the room we can make room
hey guys remember me about a week ago
i'm back again to tell you about our
sponsor bessie
bessie is a shoe that can go anywhere
and do anything i personally use messing
every day to work out it doesn't matter
if i'm outside and it's raining or i'm
inside it doesn't matter if i'm outside
hiking and it's dry and dirty and dusty
because i can just hose them off in the
backyard besties are 100 waterproof not
water resistant so they're super easy to
clean just throw them in the wash or
maybe hose them down in the backyard and
just let them dry to prove that they're
waterproof
there's nothing there
there's nothing there there's nothing
there one of my favorite things about
bessie's is they're sustainably made
they use less material less water and no
animal byproduct that means they're
vegan vessies are made with dymatex a
dual climate knit which keeps you cool
in the summer and warm in the winter i
can just slip my shoes on and off like
socks i barely feel them on my feet
they're super lightweight and breathable
sometimes i forget they're even on it
doesn't matter where you go besties has
you covered oh so do we click the link
in the description below so you can get
25 for each pair of besties you buy you
can get one for every member of the
family anyways enjoy the rest of this
video and i'll probably see you next
week because i'm coming for jake's job
so we actually got the suggestion for
looking at free guy from the comments of
these videos so if you are ryan reynolds
leave a comment down below or come on to
the show and we'll you know choose
something from that and if you're not
ryan reynolds and you just have a cool
shot you want to react to go ahead leave
a comment down below too also old vfx i
want more of them there's some great
suggestions before bed knobs and
broomsticks that's one of my favorites
that's my like my ace in my pocket bed
knobs and broomsticks yeah see these
guys don't know what it is yet they have
not seen nazis fighting reanimated
knights and armor okay i'm intrigued now
there you go all right
thank you so much for watching this was
a really fun one to do dude those tiny
people blew my mind tiny people
big results yeah
anyways
we'll see you guys in the next vfx rs
react